قال موظفون بشركه الاتصالات الفلسطينيه ان
مسيرات اسرائيليه استهدفتهم بالصواريخ
اثناء قيامهم باداء عملهم لاعاده تشغيل
الاتصالات وسط مدينه خان يونس واكدوا انه
جرى استهدافهم رغم وجود تنسيق مسبق لتاديه
عملهم عبر الصليب
الاحمر هذا لا لا الصارع زنانه زنانه
واللي في الشارع باب جاسم برضه زنانه
ايش اللي صار معكم والله احنا اتصالات
وجوال وسقنا مع الجانب اخر نصلح بحطه
الجوال وجانا واحنا قاعد بصلح
منزلين تشتغلوا يعني احنا نص ساعه عدين
بنغير بطاريات وبنشغل محطه الجال في تنس
في تنسيق
[موسيقى]
صحيحه ماخذين تنسيق وضربوا عل تعال سيدي
لو سمحت سيدي بعد اذوق
بس يا جماعه يا جماعه فعو بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يا
جماعه
وين
ياص معكم بنا عاملين تنسيق
تن لحظه لحه عيد اني معلش عاملين تنسيق
وبنا نحاول نرجع الارسال على منطقه خن
يونس واحنا بنشتغل قاعدين ونعمل صيانه
واحنا فوق يعني بيجي ساعتين ضربوا صاروخ
اول صاروخ زنا رجلي فيها شضايا وثاني
صاروخ وبعدين لما نزلنا نزلنا تحت الراي
ضربه كمان على البوابه تحت بالعافيه طلعنا
يعني بجوب طلعنا منطقه جاسر
هي تنسيق
مع ماضينا نطلع الا بتنسيق باوا منهم يا